the walls are closing in on Donald Trump
they've got him now after seven years of
constant and consistently failed
attempts to take the man down the libs
like wileyatt coyote like Elmer Fudd
with Bugs Bunny
the libs insist that they've finally got
the goods to take down Donald Trump and
the way they intend to do it is through
a 250 million dollar civil fraud suit
against Trump and his children so what
is the suit about
New York attorney general Leticia James
is Seeking a quarter of a billion
dollars on the grounds that Donald Trump
quote falsely inflated his net worth by
billions of dollars to unjustly enrich
himself and cheat
the system
I am announcing that today
we are filing a lawsuit against Donald
Trump
for violating the law as part of his
efforts to generate profits for himself
his family and his company
the complaint demonstrates that Donald
Trump falsely inflated his net worth by
billions of dollars to unjustly enrich
himself
and to cheat this system
thereby cheating all of us
he did this with the help of the other
defendants his children
Donald Trump Jr
Ivanka Trump
and Eric Trump
and former Trump organization CFO Alan
weisselberg and Trump organization
controller Jeffrey makani
Mr Trump and the Trump organization
repeatedly and persistently manipulated
the value of assets
to induce Banks
to lend money to the Trump organization
a more favorable terms than would
otherwise have been available to the
company
so in other words to translate that the
way the libs intend to get Trump after
years of failure is to claim that he
perhaps the most famous braggart
exaggerator rich guy in America
may have bragged about and exaggerated
his wealth at different times
the lawsuit is not only Preposterous but
it is actually as far as I'm concerned a
good thing for Trump in politics there's
an old saying that the only thing worse
than being talked about is not being
talked about and the fact is the libs
keep going after him on flimsier and
flimsier grounds Trump doesn't need to
worry all that much about this political
attack from a Democrat
the only time Trump will need to worry
between now and election day 2024 is
when the Democrats stop attacking him
tooth and nail I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from archetype goto
who says if you're not socially
conservative you're not actually
conservative social relates to society
Society is where we live and your
fiscally conservative money means
nothing when the society around you is
burning and rioting and censored
absolutely right if you are not a social
conservative you are not a conservative
you are not actually conserving anything
except you think your own wealth but
your own wealth is contingent on a
stable and orderly Society to be a rich
man in a country that's completely
Fallen apart is actually much worse than
being a poor man in a flourishing
Society your wealth isn't even worth
what it would be if you want to conserve
anything you must be a social
conservative otherwise you're just a
greedy short-sighted Democrat don't do
that okay we gotta we gotta conserve
stuff ourselves we got to do stuff
ourselves when you got to fix your car
yourself you got to go check out
RockAuto right right now head on over to
rockauto.com write Knowles in there how
did you hear about us box with the ever
increasing numbers of vehicle makes and
models it is impossible for a
traditional chain storefront to stock
all the parts that you need why would
you wait while the man at the counter
orders parts for your car from the brand
that his Warehouse happens to carry when
you've got a computer right there in
your pocket you can go to rockauto.com
you can get all the parts that you need
a super easy to navigate catalog for
much less money than you will pay at the
brick and mortar auto parts store you'll
save a ton of time and time is money you
will always get the most reliably low
prices same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers no gimmicks no you got
to log in at Tuesday at 3 A.M and then
you're going to save 20 none of that
always reliably low prices you go to
rockauto.com right now you get the brake
shocks carpet wipers headlights mirrors
Mufflers lug nuts and any other part you
need that's rockauto.com be sure to
write Knowles Canada w-les and they're
headed you hear about this box so they
know that we sent you if I were Donald
Trump I would be thrilled about this
lawsuit
I'd be a little irritated because it
might cost me some money it might be a
little bit of a hassle it's going to
drag me into core that would be annoying
but I would be thrilled about it because
what this lawsuit means is that Donald
Trump is still the Democrats number one
target which means that Donald Trump is
still the number one Prospect for
president for the Republicans in 2024.
that's it if Trump were not the number
one Prospect Trump would not be being
sued right now he would not be being
criminally investigated he would not be
being attacked by the Democrats
the Democrats do however have other
objects of ire and hatred right now
there was a post the other day from one
of these blue check Democrat strategists
who said gosh isn't this amazing the the
two top Republican choices for president
in 2024 Trump and DeSantis are both
under criminal investigation
yeah right exactly funny how that works
they it's it's not that they were under
criminal investigation and now they're
the top picks for the Republicans in
2024 it's the opposite they were the top
guys that is why they're under criminal
investigation and it's not just Trump
it's those two guys Ron DeSantis as well
even Libs even people who appeal
primarily to libs are pointing out Ron
DeSantis is doing a very very good job
positioning himself for the presidential
cycle
for months Republican Governors have
sent busloads of illegal immigrants to
Sanctuary cities like New York DC and
Chicago with the message of if you like
them so much they're yours okay well
just in time for Hispanic Heritage Month
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis upped the
game by sending two playing folds of
immigrants to the east coast Elite's
favorite vacation island Martha's
Vineyard Massachusetts I personally
think it's genius
I wish that Governors like Ron DeSantis
and Greg Abbott would give Democratic
Governors and Mayors more of a heads up
because then that would expose the
hypocrisy of the Democrats which is they
don't want immigrants here either
he says I personally think it's genius
and what's great about it he's he's
obviously not being tongue-in-cheek he's
not being ironic his body language is
showing that he knows he's saying
something that he's not supposed to be
saying look I personally think it's
genius and then he gives that side eye
he kind of looks to the rest of the
panel and what's really amazing is no
one on that panel Twitches a muscle
they don't disagree they don't agree
they stay perfectly still
because they know they're not allowed to
agree okay if they if they do agree with
him they might get canceled
but they also know that he's right
and they know that DeSantis is right and
so they don't they don't want to agree
with it they don't want to disagree with
it
they're just absolutely Frozen there
but of course Charlemagne is correct
Ron DeSantis is absolutely crushing it
this is a strategy that a number of
people had been talking about on the
right actually Ted Cruz came up with the
strategy
he introduced a bill in the Senate
called the Stop The Surge act which said
we're going to open new ports of entry
and we're going to relocate the migrants
to Rehoboth Beach Delaware and Martha's
Vineyard and Nantucket and the Hamptons
and all over the place but because the
Republicans don't have the Senate
majority the cruise Bill didn't go
anywhere Then Greg Abbott started to try
to ship these migrants to Liberal cities
from Miz New York City or Washington DC
or Chicago even the the migrants can
just kind of disappear these are major
American cities it causes some problems
but they can kind of paper over it it's
only when you send it to the really
really fine liberal enclaves when you
send it to Martha's Vineyard one of the
nicest beach towns in the country or
Cape Cod or the Hamptons or Republic
Delaware where Biden's from then you can
really see it okay and so it was Rhonda
Santos didn't come up with a strategy
but he did he did implement it and sort
of fine tune it and perfect it and it's
Genius of course it's genius the
Democrats have no way to respond to it
the best thing they can do is go back to
their irregular old tricks where they
say this strategy whatever the
Republicans are doing it's dangerous
it's tantamount to murder they're
putting lives at risk
has the president reached out to any of
these Governors so here's the thing and
I was asked this question earlier today
I don't know why we would reach out to a
governor or Governors who are clearly
playing a political game right it is
something that they're doing not to find
a solution but to literally literally
put people's lives at risk
to literally put those lives at risk not
figuratively not metaphorically they are
literally putting people's lives at risk
by
sending them to Martha's Vineyard
one of the nicest safest places in the
country we're putting their lives at
risk because let's say that one of the
Venezuelan illegal aliens one of the
migrants goes and gets a delicious
Martha's Vineyard lobster roll and let's
say while this migrant is sitting on the
beach enjoying that tasty Vineyard
lobster roll he discovers that he has a
shellfish allergy and he doesn't have
his EpiPen on him that hey look that his
life is at risk he's not going to be
getting lobster rolls in Del Rio or El
Paso that's for sure
of course Del Rio and El Paso and all
the Border towns are in every other way
much more dangerous to the migrants than
Martha's Vineyard or Rehoboth Beach
Delaware or Nantucket or anywhere else
but now it's putting lives at risk
unless we are misinterpreting what
Corrine Jean-Pierre is saying there
maybe what she means is not that the
migrants are at greater risk in Martha's
Vineyard than they are on the border
that's obviously Preposterous maybe what
she's saying is
that Rhonda Santos is putting the lives
of the people of Martha's Vineyard at
risk because the migrants are bringing
with them crime they're 100 of them are
bringing crime because they're they're
very presence in America is breaking one
of the most fundamental laws but
furthermore the only way that you cross
that border illegally is by paying off
the cartels these absolute Savage
animals some of the most
terrifying violent people on the planet
and then you go into debt to those
cartels and you gotta you've got to pay
back those debts when you're here in
America so yes it's true the migrants do
the ones who cross illegally bring a ton
of crime they bring a ton of violent
crime and they bring sex trafficking and
prostitution all the rest of it so yeah
that's true Rhonda Santos I guess is
putting people's lives at risk in
Martha's Vineyard by bringing the
dangerous migrants to them
fair enough but it's the people of
Martha's Vineyard it's the liberals who
are bringing the migrants into America
more generally they're the ones who are
putting the all the Border Towns at risk
and and Americans generally at risk so
okay if this is a risk to people's lives
then stop allowing the cartels to
smuggle people across the border
either way either way the narrative
coming out of the White House does not
make sense
if they wanted to make sense now that
they've been totally exposed as
hypocrites
not just my word also the word of
Charlemagne the Charlemagne the God a
liberal radio host if they want to uh to
seem even somewhat coherent here what
they're going to have to do is send
those migrants back just the same way
that the people of Martha's Vineyard
deported those migrants to a military
Camp within 44 hours so too the
Democrats at the national level need to
send these people back Joe Biden says
can't do it it's just not rational
there are fewer
for fewer immigrants coming from Central
America and from Mexico this is totally
different circumstance what's on my
watch now is Venezuela Cuba and
Nicaragua and the ability to send them
back to those States is not rational
you could send them back and have them
while we're working with Mexico and
other countries to see if we can stop
the flow but that's the difference thank
you
migrants to Delaware do you have any
comment or response to that sir
he should come visit we have a beautiful
Shoreline
he should come visit Delaware I like
Delaware what's going on in Delaware bye
everybody
it's just not rational yes the White
House is not being rational right now
what does he mean it's not rational to
deport the migrants it it is rational to
deport foreigners who are coming into
your country against the will of your
citizens and against the your nation's
laws it is very rational to deport them
of course it is it's very rational for
political leaders who are accountable to
to their people who are actually
accountable to their constituents to do
what Their constituents want within the
bounds of the law that's very rational
but I think what what he's trying to
imply by the rationality here is look if
they were just Mexicans it would be we
would be rational to send them back to
Mexico but these guys come from
Venezuela and that's not rational to
send them back why not
is he I I can't tell if he's actually
trying to make this argument or if he's
just gotten confused and is babbling as
he often does but is he actually
suggesting that because we share a
border with Mexico we can send them back
but because we would need
an airplane we would it's it would be
it's not rational to send the
Venezuelans back we have airplanes we
send migrants around on airplanes all
the time Joe Biden sends migrants around
on airplanes how come it's rational to
take illegal aliens who cross the Rio
Grande and end up in Texas why is it
rational to put them on an airplane and
ship them into the interior of the
United States but it's not rational to
take those same migrants on those same
airplanes and bring them back to the
countries that they are actually
citizens of
why
it's the opposite right it's much more
rational to send them back to their own
countries it's much less rational to put
them on the airplane send them into the
middle of America
why is it we can't send them to
Venezuela which is where they're from we
can't send them to Martha's Vineyard
which is where all the liberal Elites
live but we we can send them to Red
States and purple districts and Border
towns we can do that why is that how is
that rational
doesn't it has nothing to do with
rationality has nothing to do with
reason or a logical argument it has
everything to do with power Politics the
migrants are more politically useful to
Biden in the purple districts and the
red States than they are to Biden either
in Martha's Vineyard or in their own
countries because Mass migration is the
primary electoral strategy of the
Democrats and has been for 50 years more
than 50 years
that's why it's not it's not about
rationality or reason or Justice it's
about bare-knuckle brawling political
interest and the Democrats are willing
to force their political will which is
unjust and conservatives are not at all
willing until very very recently at
least
to to pursue their own political will
and exercise political power which is
just
speaking of Joe Biden's lack of
rationality this could be a topic for
weeks and weeks you know Joe Biden said
a couple of days ago that the covid
pandemic is over this was in his
interview with 60 minutes
really really great news wonderful stuff
this is the one glimmer of hope that we
saw out of that whole interview
and then of course because it was a
glimmer of hope the White House had to
come back the White House whatever the
White House is had to come back and
contradict the president of the United
States
the President also in the 60 Minutes
interview said that the pandemic is over
there's been quite a bit of pushback to
that statement by the president where is
he today on that so I just to step back
for a second what we saw during that
interview uh 60-minute interview when he
made those comments he was walking
through uh the the Detroit car show the
halls of the Detroit car show and he was
looking around we have to remember the
last time that they had held that event
was three years ago even as we're
talking about unga the president's going
to speak shortly as I just mentioned we
that hasn't been held in in person for
about three years as well so we are in a
different time he's been very consistent
about that and the reason why is because
we are now prepared we are now ready we
know how to deal with this pandemic it
is now more manageable it's not as
disruptive now what he has been very
consistent about is that we have to
continue to have a front foot on this so
we have the funding so that we are ahead
of this of any other you know as we look
at Future vaccines and future treatments
can anybody translate that into English
for me that was a whole lot of words to
say ignore the president because the
president said the pandemic is over
and then his spokesman said the pandemic
is not over
and then the spokesman said implausibly
no no the president has been very very
consistent that the pandemic is not over
for instance when he said a couple of
days ago that the pandemic is over what
he really meant was the pandemic is not
over it's some sometimes when he says
one thing he actually means it's
opposite and so that's why he's been so
consistent and that's why the pandemic
is not over
now what does this mean it means that
Joe Biden misspeaks well Joe Biden was
actually right the pen the pandemic has
been over for years at this point and
the pandemic was never nearly as uh
great a threat to People's Health as the
lib said that it was but the libs wanted
to take a lot of power and so they
exploited it and were able to
rig a presidential election and lock us
all down for for two years almost two
and a half years as a result of that a
topic for another day Joe Biden actually
was right his White House his spokesman
is wrong on the issue
however
the White House and his spokesman
apparently have the final say
it's not as though the White House some
spokesman came out and said something
and Biden came out and said no that's BS
we're doing it my way it was the
opposite Biden nominally the president
of the United States says something
and then the White House corrects him
and the White House gets its way so it
raises this question beyond kovid beyond
the lockdowns
who is running the country who is making
the shots
this has been hotly debated
some people think it's a shadowy cabal
of former Obama type people some people
think it's Ron Clane the white house
chief of staff some people say it's the
Deep stay in the bureaucracy and some
people have are you know it's Joe Biden
Joe Biden is the decider ultimately he
might not know which end is up but he's
making the decisions when you're
president you're president I I think
that the only theory that we can
completely disregard is that last Theory
because every time now that Joe Biden
disagrees with
the White House which should be
synonymous Joe Biden in the white house
should be the same thing but they're not
and every time there's a disagreement
between the two Joe Biden loses
so Joe Biden is obviously not calling
the shots here
that's a big big problem for
self-government
even even if you think that there are
some questions surrounding the 2020
election and the way that all the rules
were changed right beforehand in the way
that it took weeks to finish counting
the ballots and the way that there were
all sorts of strange anomalies okay
regardless of that
at least Joe Biden ostensibly represents
the will of the American people he
ostensibly was elected and is an
accountable
official in the United States
and not even that guy is calling the
shot so who is who is how much of a say
do we really have in our government
how much of us say do we really have in
our sacred democracy that the libs keep
babbling about even as they continue to
suppress the Democratic elements in our
government including Joe Biden including
the guy that they say is their elected
president
that that's what when Kareem Jean-Pierre
once wants a policy to go through and
Joe Biden wants a policy to go through
green jumpier gets her way speaking of
black women
John boyega who is an actor I think he
was in the new Star Wars movies John
boyega and I mentioned this a little bit
at the end of the show yesterday is
making headlines because he said an
audacious shocking thing he said that he
a black guy only dates black women
two GQ he said I only date black
then it's about chemistry personality
goals is there a Synergy can I help you
can you help me
again it's kind of a tawdry and clinical
way to view a love affair can I help you
can you help me can we advance each
other's interests okay I love you honey
I know let's do it let's Advance each
other's interests that's not what Cole
Porter's saying no uh not a great way to
look at love but he's saying look that's
how it is and uh and then he got in
trouble because he said he only dates
black chicks and when he got pushed back
he said when people talk about
preferring brunettes or blondes they're
not talking about wearing a wig my
preference is not a topic for debate
and I agree with him here
why is why is it wrong for a black guy
to to prefer to date black chicks I
don't think why is it wrong for a
Japanese guy to prefer to date Japanese
chicks
why is it wrong for a White Guy to
prefer to date White Chicks oh that's
very wrong
you see because John boyega will get
away with this he will ultimately won't
get in trouble
because black people can't be racist
if a Japanese guy wanted to date a
Japanese chick he probably wouldn't get
in trouble but if if a white actor came
out and said I only date white I only
date White Chicks it would be a national
Scandal he would certainly be canceled
from Hollywood he would never work again
he would he would be called a Ku Klux
klansman
why
why I don't see any problem with any of
that for any people
one it's
difficult to control one's preferences
not saying it's impossible to shape
one's preferences but genetics and the
way that you are raised in culture and
nurture are going to shape those things
why is it that John boyega has to date
uh I don't know a middle eastern chick
why does he have to date a white chick
or a
Chinese check
for to advance political correctness is
the man not allowed to have the love
affairs that he wants is the man not
allowed to pick the wife that he wants
shouldn't that be the case for all of us
why do why do we have to suppress
perfectly ordinary normal things all in
the name of political correctness
I think it's fine
I I hereby uncancel John boyega John
boyega find in my book those movies are
not fine in my book but John boyega is
fun tonight you know is a brand new
episode of Ben Shapiro's book club at 8
pm Eastern on dailywireplus.com this
month's book is All the King's Men tune
in to hear Ben discuss the book and
share his notes with you you must be an
all-access member to join in on the fun
head on over to dailywireplus.com become
a member today join Ben Shapiro's book
club tonight at 8 pm Eastern
speaking of racial identity
Sunny Hosten on the view is not just
attacking Trump
not even just attacking Ron DeSantis
there is a third Republican Prospect for
president that the libs are beginning to
go after that would be Nikki Haley how
are they going after her on racial
grounds
I think we've got some if they're
willing to challenge Trump I'd love to
see Nikki Haley I'd love to see Liz
Cheney I'd love to see Nikki Haley the
chameleon and Nick and Liz Cheney I
disagree I think I think that Nikki
Haley was incredibly effective
wait Alice I have a question aside from
Rhonda a lot of a lot of people don't go
by their actual room
I believe it's uh I don't want to
mispronounce it it's Indian but she's
the background isn't necessarily you
know I think if she leaned into a ton of
people don't go by there
so Nikki Haley's given name is not
actually Nikki it's some Indian sounding
name but she goes by Nikki because this
is America and people speak English and
because she's in politics and I don't
know and maybe just because she prefers
the name Nikki that's fine it's very
nice name
and sunny Hosten is saying that's wrong
she can't do that she's not allowed to
take on a more English sounding name
that according to Sunny hoston
whose name is
annuncia or annunciata or something it's
a Spanish version of of the name for the
think it's
I think it's annuncia or something no
I'm sorry Asuncion there it is so it's
not it's not the enunciation it's the
assumption but she's got a Spanish name
it's a very nice name and she prefers to
go by
an anglicized version of that
what do we take away from this two
things
has nothing to do with the names what
names people want to go by they go after
Ted Cruz for this very same thing Ted
Cruz's name is Raphael Edward Cruz but
his father in its name is also Raphael
so when Ted was a kid people would call
him philito and felito is not a name
that a young young American boy wants to
be called or really any boy wants to be
called I think and he was sort of
getting made fun of for that name and so
he went with a nickname that is part of
one of his names
a nickname for Edward his middle name is
Ted and he goes by Ted okay is there any
problem with that I don't see any
problem with that especially if you're
living in America America we speak
English for now
and we we speak it at least relatively
coherently before all the woke people
redefine all the words and so he goes by
Ted that's fine certainly makes a lot
more sense than some by somebody by the
name of uh Robert Francis O'Rourke going
by Beto
it's kind of weird for a White Guy with
an English sounding name Irish sounding
name to go by a Spanish name when he
lives in America which ostensibly is
supposed to speak English but okay even
beta whatever or sunny hosta wants to go
by sunny but Nikki Haley's not allowed
to do it Beto's allowed to go by Beto
Ted's not allowed to go by Ted Asuncion
is allowed to go by Sunny Nikki is not
allowed to go by Nikki
why because it has nothing to do with
any principle it has nothing to do with
any names it has nothing to do with any
kind of racial politics even it's really
just because
half of those people are Democrats half
of those are people are Republicans
it it isn't even on the basis of race
Nikki Haley is Indian and Ted Cruz is
Cuban and Irish and Italian a bunch of
other things
and Beto O'Rourke is a white guy and
sunny Hosten is Hispanic
but it actually doesn't have to do with
rate it's just the Democrats get to do
whatever the Democrats want the
Republicans can't do anything right and
that's it so there's no principle here
and as we approach the 2022 midterms and
as we get into 2024 we have to remember
as these attacks kick up we have to
remember they are completely baseless
there is no reason to take any of them
seriously actually you don't have to
hand it to the Democrats it's completely
in bad faith it's all Bs just laugh it
off and ignore it for goodness sakes
they're going after Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley who I really like personally Nikki
Haley is a very moderate politician okay
and I promise you if Nikki Haley somehow
got the Republican nominee in 2024 they
would call her Ava Braun okay and they'd
probably call her Hitler they'd probably
just go all the way and call her Hitler
they would find a way to make Nikki
Haley a far right radical semi-fascist
anyone they would do it to anybody
okay and they'd find all these ways to
attack her
that that
come from principles that they would
never hold themselves by and it's all
just so fake just totally ignore it okay
you know you know where you see this
most clearly is when the libs talk about
political violence there was I meant to
get to this yesterday we'll get to it
now horrible horrifying example of
political violence a 41 year old liberal
just murdered a poor 18 year old
Republican kid
specifically because the kid was a
Republican
that's it there are no additional
factors here this is in in all of the
reporting and apparently in the guy's
own words
this 41 year old liberal killed this
poor 18 year old kid
because he viewed the 18 year old kid as
a quote Republican extremist
they had a debate over politics and then
the 41 year old Dem killed the 18 year
old Republican
ran them over with this car then
the good news is this 41 year old Dem
was charged with vehicular homicide and
then the bad news is because we have
completely abandoned the justice system
in this country when it is politically
convenient for Democrats the guy got out
on bond fifty thousand dollar Bond the
guy's out the guy murders an 18 year old
kid
simply for the crime of being a
republican runs him over with a car then
gets out on fifty thousand dollar Bond
there there are basically no examples of
political violence from the right in
recent years
but one example do you remember there's
one example from that unite the right
rally where a right-wing guy
apparently hit a left-wing gal with his
car and it was considered the worst
terrorist attack ever the guy is for
sure gonna rot if he doesn't receive the
death penalty he was he was considered
worse than Hitler I mean and he
committed a terrible crime and he's
paying the punishment for it
this Democrat guy committed
the exact same crime
much more clearly by the way too at
least with the unite the right rally
there was a ton of political violence
going on on both sides it was a melee
there was basically gang violence going
on in the street here it was just two
guys it was an older Democrat guy who
got into an argument about politics with
a young Democrat teenage or a young
Republican teenager and then
he decided to get in his car
premeditated no political violence going
on around him and just mow this guy down
and he gets out fifty thousand dollar
Bond you you won't hear about this from
the liberal Outlets
all of the political violence
statistically all of it is coming from
the left and we are getting speeches
from the president of the United States
calling Republicans extremist fascist
domestic terrorists Biden's doj is
referring to ordinary citizens as
domestic terrorists parents who question
their child's curricula in school and
the fact that the kids are being taught
critical race Theory and radical gender
Theory are being referred to as as
extremists real
potentially violent threats in America
and the doj and the FBI are looking into
them it's just so bogus
okay obviously there are two two Justice
systems in America
and so why do I say it again not just to
point out the hypocrisy and try to
reason with the libs and get them to
change their minds that's not what's
going to happen I'm really trying to
reason with the Republicans here and the
conservatives and say hey guys
especially the squishes in the middle
this is all fake never give in an inch
don't talk about January 6th don't talk
about the violent threats from the
Republicans it's all just made up guys
and where it's not made up there is like
the tiniest little minuscule half kernel
of truth that is then blown into
proportions that take it into the realm
of the Absurd meanwhile actual very
clear
violence and threats and all sorts of
other nefarious things from the left are
completely ignored and in fact even
Justified
okay it's just a liberal narrative that
is totally fake just ignore it okay
ignore it and just keep on keeping on
and laugh at these people when they
accuse you of anything
the the liberal narrative we we had a
wonderful opportunity the other day to
pull up a big bag of popcorn and get a
front row seat to watching a liberal
narrative collapse in real time this
went viral it was Don Lemon on CNN
interviewing a British journalist about
the Queen's death and Don Lemon
just like all the libs trying to use any
political or historical event to to
rewrite that event and then use it to
push his own political agenda that is
totally divorced from reality one thing
I love about the British they're just
they've just got a sort of Grace to them
you know they're they've got a sort of
ease in the way that they speak in the
way that they can make an argument
listen to how this British journalist
just artfully dismantles Don lemon's
stupid argument about the queen
well this is coming when you know this
all of this wealth and you hear about it
comes as England is facing Rising costs
of living a living crisis austerity
budget cuts and so on and then you have
those who are asking uh for reparations
for colonialism and they're wondering
you know 100 billion dollars 24 billion
dollars here and there 500 million there
some people want to be paid back and uh
and members of the public are wondering
why are we suffering when you are you
know you have all of this vast wealth
those are legitimate concerns
well I think you're right about
reparations in terms of if people want
it though what they need to do is you
always need to go back to the beginning
of a supply chain where was the
beginning of the supply chain that was
in Africa and when that crossed the
entire world when slavery was taking
place which was the first nation in the
world that abolished slavery the first
nation in the world to abolish it it was
started by William Wilberforce was the
British in in Great Britain they
abolished slavery 2
000 Naval men died on the high seas
trying to stop slavery why because the
African kings were rounding up their own
people they had them on cages waiting in
the beaches no one was running into
Africa to get them and I think you're
totally right if reparations need to be
paid we need to go right back to the
beginning of that supply chain and say
who was rounding up their own people and
having them hangcrafting Pages
absolutely that's where they should
start and maybe I don't know the
descendants of those families where they
died in the high seas trying to stop the
slavery that those families should
receive something too I think same time
it's an interesting discussion Hillary
thank you very much I appreciate it
yeah it is an interesting discussion
isn't it Don Lemon I love to she did it
so gracefully that he he couldn't even
fight back against her obviously he
doesn't have any facts at his disposal
he was just spouting nonsense and she
just so gracefully with a nice little
smile she said we had actually Don Lemon
uh the stupid point that you're making
uh really ought to be flipped on its
head because the British are the least
culpable in the entire world for slavery
I don't know I'm kind of doing a little
bit of a of a Paul McCartney man you
know I don't know that I can really do a
proper British accent like she's doing
but that's the point that she's making
okay and Don lemon's there and he's it's
just like he was hit by a freight train
he just ab and he and then hit the
narrative
you had the narrative kind of chucking
along and then that British journalist
came because she had some not only moral
Clarity and not only the facts at her
side but the courage to go on CNN and
say nah all that politically correct
mumbo jumbo it's all completely BS Don
Lemon and if anything the Africans are
the British an apology for slavery
it just completely destroys the
narrative you know housing prices are
falling inflation is Raging harder than
a Finnish prime minister on a Saturday
night but the news is not all Bleak in
just a few short months Jeremy's razors
kneecapped Harry's Racers tens of
thousands of people like you have stood
up to woke razor companies and said
enough is enough and for that we want to
thank you with the new Jeremy's razors
contest for the car here's how it works
for every person you refer whether they
buy a Jeremy's razor kit or a daily wire
annual membership you both get points in
the race to win the god Kings McLaren
this is not just a masculine car
this car actually spells out the word
masculine in exhaust fumes refer enough
of your friends to Jeremy's and you just
might win it I am not joking this is
totally real if someone in our audience
wins this car
I would be very very proud and then
probably ask for a ride somewhere the
race for the car ends on November 1st so
get in the competition today go to
Jeremy's racers.com play see terms and
conditions for complete details at
Jeremy's racers.com referral terms the
program is open only to Legal us
residents residing in the U.S DC
excluding residents of Colorado
Connecticut Maryland Puerto Rico and U.S
territories and possessions 18 and older
remember friends don't let friends shave
with woke razors
Don Lemon totally destroyed with facts
and logic
I I hope I I would if we had more time I
would play that clip again just so that
conservatives can take notes on how that
woman did it because I bet you when
confronted with the same BS narrative
from Don Lemon
I bet you
99.7 of American conservatives would not
give anywhere nearly as bold an answer
as that woman did Don Lemon is pitching
this lib line that we've heard about
well the queen she's actually a sort of
complicated figure because of
colonialism and the legacy of slavery
and all this just complete nonsense for
Queen Elizabeth is not only not a
complicated figure she is probably the
Least Complicated figure in modern
history
she's just a woman who did her Duty
Faithfully
name me a queen scandal there were
scandals with her kids there were
scandals with some members of her family
name me a scandal from the queen
name me a policy of the queen or some
initiative from the queen that's really
controversial and I can't you can't name
one
they got nothing
the only the only attacks I've heard on
the queen that that the libs have been
repeating with any success whatsoever is
you know she knighted a guy maybe who
turned out to be a jerk or sh but
they've got nothing or her kids were
jerks sure but they got nothing she's
not complicated at all and then even the
historical narrative that Don Lemon is
trying to push is just BS this is how
conservatives should talk about it not
only should we not say well we've got to
apologize for the original sin of
slavery forget it in Great Britain in
America you know it's the original sin
of this country and we will we will
never get that stain off of our country
what are you talking about America is
not only not the most responsible for
slavery in the world America is one of
the least responsible countries for
slavery in the entire world
okay we we had slavery in America for a
very very short period of time compared
with the rest of the world we had
slavery in the modern sense of the term
in the West for a very very short period
of time compared to the rest of the
world
where did we get the slaves from because
Africans were enslaving their own people
and still are today by the way
not nearly as much as they were at the
time of the transatlantic slave trade
but to some degree they still are
where did we get slavery from because
North Africa not just sub-Saharan
Africans but North Africans were and
continue to
be enslaving people
for a long time the Muslims in North
Africa controlled a major major slave
trade for a very very long time you
still see slavery in East Asia you still
see slavery everywhere in the world
other than in the United States and in
America
and we fought a bloody Civil War over
the issue of slavery
if anyone should be apologizing for
slavery it is everybody else on earth
except for us okay that's the real
answer
and I think it's silly to apologize for
slavery generally because it's a just an
expression of the fallenness of the
human heart right not not a pathology
unique to the West
if the only thing that's unique to the
West here is that we got rid of it
quickly and realized how bad it was
but it's it's a a problem that afflicts
the entire world because man is a fallen
creature so but so I don't think that we
all need to go around flogging ourselves
and apologizing for slavery but if
anyone is going to do that it should be
the Africans and the Arabs and the north
Africans and the Asians and basically
everybody other than the West once all
those other people apologize then maybe
the West can start apologizing for
slavery but until then it's obviously
that's never going to happen
so just
get rid of it it's a bunk narrative you
don't you you really don't have to hand
it to the libs you really don't need to
give it to them or meet in the middle or
reconciled BS just totally ignore it
speaking of
slavery false imprisonment
Governor Gavin Newsom
who really really really wants to run
for president he's clearly the most
ambitious of the Democrats who could be
the nominee in 2024. he is accusing
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis of
kidnapping the illegal aliens
that he had given a a nice vacation in
Martha's Vineyard too kidnapping
and why was he kidnapping because he had
these migrants sign forms to say yes I
want to get on this plane I want to go
to this place you can see it they all
signed their names but you know they
didn't really know what they were
signing and so it's been pretty much
kidnapping to force them all to go up
and have lobster rolls by the cape
kidnapping
putting migrants on buses or planes is
kidnapped illegal aliens by the way is
kidnapping according to Governor Gavin
Newsom
if these people don't really know what
they're doing it's just wrong to ship
them out of your jurisdiction except
that Gavin Newsom did exactly the same
thing
Gavin Newsom where is I've got a whole
article about this
oh yeah Gavin Newsom
this from 2006. back when Newsome was
running San Francisco
San Francisco put the homeless on buses
and shipped them out of the city because
Newsome realized that nobody wants the
homeless people all just lazing about
shooting up drugs threatening people you
know defecating on the streets that was
back before San Francisco totally lost
its mind and he realized it's this is
the homeless people don't have a right
to do this this is totally disordered so
we're just going to get him out of here
you put them on buses and he sent them
home he did he did exactly what Rhonda
Sanders did except that Gavin Newsom put
them on crappy buses and sent them to
sort of crappy places and Ron DeSantis
chartered a jet and sent the migrants to
Martha's Vineyard
but he so so Gavin Newsom just did a
much less Pleasant version of what Ron
DeSantis did but when when DeSantis does
it it's compassion it's it's evil I'm
sorry it's evil it's terrible it's
kidnapping it's slavery when Newsome
does the the very same thing in a worse
way it's wonderful it's compassionate
it's fine Move Along Move Along no
principle here folks no principle and I
just I'm just putting my warning out
here now as we head into the midterms
and into 2024.
I will have no quarter for the squishes
I've never really had much quarter for
the squishes but certainly none now as
things have accelerated as the labs have
seized more and more power as they spent
eight months bringing the country down
as they are regularly not just
threatening the livelihoods and lives of
conservatives but actually attacking
them trying to assassinate Brett
Kavanaugh killing 18 year old Republican
kids just for being Republicans calling
out these are elected officials
saying we encourage you to go to the
Republicans homes to attack their
families to go confront them in the
streets and then the elected officials
bailing out the the violent Marauders
after they commit these acts because
these these Street people are the
military wing of the Democrat Party I
just have no quarter for the squishes I
just I don't want to hear about well the
scientists shouldn't have done it in
that way well Trump actually shouldn't
have tweeted that way well actually you
know you got to hand it to them you know
you don't have to hand them anything
pick a side man you know do I have
disagreements with the Republican Party
lots of them do I think that every
Republican running for office is a great
guy who will even do a semi-good job no
I don't but come on man the stakes
couldn't be clearer okay the libs are
are intentionally opening up all of our
borders flooding our country with
millions of foreign Nationals letting
the prisoners out of jail encouraging
violence against us destroying the
economy come on give me a break it's not
that complicated
you don't you don't need that much
Nuance you don't need to hand it to them
speaking of Dems
speaking of Dems letting the criminals
out
John fetterman
running running for Senate in
Pennsylvania even though
he's he can't really be on the campaign
Trail because he can't actually really
speak and even when his health was
better he he was still a radical
candidate who was not particularly
coherent John fetterman it has come out
really wants to free murderers okay he
said if he had a magic wand what he
would do is the first thing he would do
he wouldn't cure cancer he wouldn't you
know end world hunger what what he would
do is let murderers out of prison and he
did vote to let murders out of prison
including one man who
this is this is just a delightful report
from the Washington Free Beacon a
fetterman voted to free a murderer who
hacked an innocent man to death with
garden shears so this this murderer
uh Charles Zeke Goldblum was sentenced
to life in prison for killing a man with
a garden shears and then
then when the guy got out
he hired a hit man to murder his
accomplice in the murder
and John fetterman
voted to let that guy go free
why
probably
if I want to be as charitable as I can
possibly be
it's because
the libs just have a completely
perverted understanding of justice and
the libs believe that the perpetrators
are the victims and the victims deserve
no justice right that's what the libs
think about it the only reason that this
poor man hacked his neighbor to death
with garden shears and then murdered his
accomplice tried to murder his
accomplice is because Society failed him
it's your fault it's the fault of the
Bourgeois culture and Society
if only Society had been different then
the man wouldn't have hacked his
neighbor to death with garden shears and
that's why it's really he's really the
victim here and we need to let him out
he's paid his debt to society because he
stayed in prison for five seconds this
this awful Democrat who murdered an 18
year old Republican simply for being a
republican he had to sit in prison he
had to sit in jail for a few hours he's
paid his debt to save a society that
failed him really it was the Republicans
hanging him on you know those violent
extremists they made him do it what's a
man to do there's Republicans are such
violent extremists sometimes they wear
horn hats into the capital rotunda and
take selfies you know those were those
awful Republican extremists who
sometimes when they get a little bit of
political power want to enforce any of
the laws they're just really
semi-fascist extremists
awful so that's the charitable view of
John Federman but the the more cynical
and I think realistic view of why the
Dems want to let all the criminals out
it's because it creates chaos and it
allows them to take more power
and because the people that they're
letting out attack Republicans
I think they I think they choose to
permit and even encourage the BLM riots
because it helps them and it intimidates
their political opponents meanwhile as I
mentioned earlier I alluded to the horn
hat guy you know it's a Midwestern
grandmas show up to the Capitol One day
and don't kill anybody and don't really
do anything other than make a mess of
the Rotunda that's considered the worst
terrorist attack we got to shut that
down we got to throw them in solitary
confinement because that's not that's
not helpful to The Republic to the
Democrats political agenda that's what
that's what this is really about a raw
exercise of power you don't need to to
hand it to Democrats you don't need to
give them anything okay the rest of this
show is continuing now by the way then
I'm after the show I'm flying out to
Milwaukee because I'm going to be
appearing tonight at uh Wisconsin
Lutheran College it's going to be a ton
of fun the Catholic university
University of St Thomas won't have me
they disinvite me for saying Christian
things but the Lutheran College will
have me how about that that's pretty
ecumenical so head on there it's free
and open to the public if you can make
it in Milwaukee it's going to be a ton
of fun if you can't make it or even if
you can head on over to the block if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us we've got a
great interview coming up see you there
[Music]
[Music]